hello everybody my name is simon allison
i am the africa editor for the mail and
guardian newspaper
and editor of the continent the
pan-african weekly news magazine
i am speaking today to france timmermans
the european commission's executive vice
president
for the european green deal mr
timmermans
welcome now vice president every month
we all know that the climate crisis was
not caused by african countries
the continent only contributes around
four percent of global carbon emissions
what is europe's responsibility when it
comes to helping africa to cope with
this crisis
i think first of all our two continents
uh are siamese twins
if if africa does well europe will do
well if europe does well
it can really provide some support for
africa as well
um if europe suffers it will not be
focusing on the importance of working
together with africa
if africa suffers the problems will come
to europe without any any doubt
uh so the sooner everybody understands
this the sooner we can find solutions
now what i've
what i've seen over the last year is
really a change of heart
on both sides um i think finally
finally the europeans are getting rid of
their paternalistic
uh attitude towards africa because
i see everywhere we're looking at
african plans we're not bringing plans
to africa
secondly you know even though africa
isn't responsible at all
for the situation we're in africa is
already experiencing the consequence of
that situation so i think there's a
a huge also global responsibility but
also specific european responsibility
to help africa with uh mitigation and
adaptation
uh in in this climate crisis that
already has huge effects you know look
at the droughts look at the storms
look at the weather that has become
completely unpredictable look at the
locusts
uh infestations we've had in eastern
africa so yeah that that's where we need
to
to to be partners and secondly apart
from adaptation and
and mitigation uh it's about time that
every
young african wherever they live had
access to
the internet had access to electricity
uh
and that could only happen if we embrace
the idea that we can
decentralize electricity generation
bring it to
villages everywhere and for that you
need renewable energy for that you need
solar power you need wind
you will need hydrogen at some point and
also in all these
things uh we can work together and and
specifically on south africa and
a number of other countries you need to
wean yourselves of coal which is going
to be a
huge huge challenge as well
absolutely um i mean how do you respond
to the argument that
well you know you know europe um was
able to benefit from
from very cheap fossil fuels for decades
to fuel
its growth and africa should be allowed
to do the same thing
i think africa has a huge opportunity
with its young and vibrant
population to leapfrog over a number of
developments and to at least
avoid some of the worst mistakes we made
in europe
uh over the last 150 years um
so if you first create a bigger
dependency
on fossil fuels to then have to wean
yourselves from that
is more difficult than to immediately
try and embrace
uh new forms of energy and i'm more and
more enthusiastic about
uh what i see in in in different in
western africa in some countries in
eastern africa
as in ethiopia earlier this year and
also there you know the understanding
that you can have
villages with their own power generation
based on solar and wind
is bringing sort of it's it's also a
form of emancipation and it's also a
form of
bringing more social justice also to
remoter areas and countries
mr timmermans you have been leading
efforts to introduce
a green deal in europe um
can you tell us a little bit about what
this might mean for africa
i think it would mean that you
uh bring new forms of energy generation
or or
upscale them the potential for solar
energy in africa is huge
don't have to explain that the potential
for carbon sink you know through your
natural
environment through forests and
grasslands etc is also huge
um potential to because you know
we also have a biodiversity crisis we're
losing
one million species if we're not very
careful the potential for africa
to contribute to our biodiversity
resilience worldwide is huge we need to
stop
uh a deforestation of primal forests in
africa that's
of huge importance but especially the
potential for younger people to learn
trades to
study to be part of an economy that's
going to be extremely
uh vibrant is huge you know africa has
such potential
and the green deal is a growth strategy
it's not just about
tackling the climate crisis it's also
about bringing about
new forms of economy a circular economy
no longer based on fossil fuels no
longer based on
on wasting commodities but rather on
recycling and on reusing etc
and for africa this has a huge uh
potential you know recycling and reusing
is not something
most africans are unfamiliar with how
you know when you have these
conversations with other african leaders
um
how receptive are they to these kinds of
ideas
well i think that the
what's driving this i think frankly is
worries about climate change which i see
have increased
uh exponentially in in most if not all
african countries
secondly they see economic opportunity
um given the fact that we're also in an
industrial revolution and as i said
before
africa would have the possibility to
leapfrog over a number of stages in our
economic development if it is done right
thirdly i think what really is important
to note
is that more and more european countries
are
not talking to african countries by
saying we know what's good for you
but saying we're listening to you how
can we help
how can we be part of this because we
see opportunities
for us as well and then of course
there's also the elements
that i really welcome in an increasing
number of african countries
the the societal structures we have in
europe uh the rule of law freedom of the
media
uh a vibrant ngo community things that
um
especially many young africans aspire to
as well and and if politicians have any
sense they they would cater to those
aspirations rather than suppress them
there was a major vote in the european
parliament
to cut carbon emissions by 60 percent by
the year 2030.
first of all congratulations that's a
major accomplishment
but what we have seen already is that
you know
when confronting carbon emissions some
companies
choose to simply outsource those
emissions to other parts of the world
um how are you going to prevent european
companies and countries from simply
outsourcing their emissions to africa
yeah this is i'm really glad you raised
this because
this is a trap we should avoid we've
seen it before with waste
with plastics you know we get rid of our
problem by
bringing that stuff elsewhere and we
should avoid this from happening here
this will depend a lot
on the strategic partnerships we want to
develop with african countries
it would also depend a lot on the
behavior of private investors that we
can influence
so how can africa contribute to this i
think
to look very much at governance uh
investment protection at
working together with us to make sure
that we can attract
investment and also we should you know
we should
address the issue of of global corporate
governance
uh with a lot of force you know if you
if europeans get all worked up
over deforestation in africa in latin
america
they should all get worked up as well
about who's responsible for this
uh and and sometimes the responsibility
lies with the european companies so
we also have an issue to tackle here of
corporate
responsibility and i i hope we can
convince the majority in the european
parliament and in the council
uh to hold our companies accountable for
this
and if they don't uh if they're not
accountable that would have consequences
for their cooperation and their support
in this transition so just to clarify
will you be pushing for
legislation that that specifically um
regulates the way that companies behave
in other parts of the world
well first of all i think this should be
part and parcel of any trade
agreements we sign with other parts of
the world
secondly i think this should be part of
the uh
strategic agreements we reach with the
african union and with
individual african nations thirdly i
think
uh corporate uh governance uh
internationally
should also be part of the proposals we
make
for legislation in europe and i know my
colleagues are working on this we've
been working on this in the past but we
need to
improve that um so i think on all these
levels we can
make sure that we don't have these
negative consequences that are indeed
a trap we should avoid i want to get on
to the issue of
migration of course we know that there
has been a wave of migration from
african countries to europe
driven at least in part by changing
climate conditions
we've seen the conditions in camps like
moria in greece we've seen the boats
left to drown in the mediterranean at
the same time
you know you've had instances of europe
giving money to dictators like omar
al-bashir to try and prevent migration
from occurring
in this context you know how can we
trust europe to do the right thing
well i think the only way we could
actually
come to solutions that are effective
but also morally acceptable is
when we address the root causes of all
this you know once
young people have paid smugglers
in their home countries and are on their
way
and and risk their lives in the sahara
or elsewhere and then mr lives again on
sea
it's in fact already too late you know
the only way we're going to solve this
is if
young people have enough confidence in
their own futures in their own countries
that they don't feel the need to migrate
or when they feel the need to migrate to
work in europe that we have a legal
system whereby they can apply for visas
in a way that is realistic
in a way that gives them an opportunity
to come to europe and i think
only if we do that can we find solutions
i mean
i hear what you're saying but you know
we've got countries like like italy and
greece which have taken a very hard-line
approach to
both refugees asylum seekers
and economic migrants you know arriving
on their shores
how are you going to get them to toe the
line well first of all
we need to be fair to those countries
for many many many years they've had
a very liberal very open attitude to
refugees
and then of course uh because of the war
in syria and because of other reasons
they were at some point overwhelmed they
asked their european friends
to help them and got very little
almost no response and at some point
they started to wave through
um these migrants and refugees
and then other other countries in europe
uh accused that
them of not following the rules which
they didn't but they had
asked for help for such a long time so
the problem here is in essence a problem
of moral hazard within the european
union
european nations who don't trust each
other some nations who think they are
doing too much
other nations are saying yeah i'm not at
the border but
all these refugees end up in my country
although i'm not at the border
and also a third group of nations uh who
say we can't be bothered
you're on your own we're not helping and
all of this has contributed to
to to a very poisonous cocktail of moral
hazard
in europe and and and the ones who pay
the highest price in this context
context are the refugees and the
migrants so that's why we're trying to
to change that paradigm to to to come up
with ideas
realistic ideas about shared solidarity
about
sharing the burden uh but also uh
realistic solutions to provide clarity
in the shortest possible time to people
who present themselves at european
borders demanding asylum
whether they have the right to that
asylum or not
what are some of those those solutions
as i said
um you know if we if we don't talk about
tackling the issue
at the source we'll not succeed so we
need to provide we need to do everything
we can
to provide more opportunity in african
countries themselves
sometimes countries grow very quickly
but then the economic growth
falls into the hands of a very very
small elite and even very well-educated
young people feel
cut out of their own society so they
look um
for opportunity elsewhere and and this
has to change i mean
i i think there's probably very few
african leaders who don't understand
that they need to change this so
where we can contribute through an
erasmus program which which offers
higher education
uh through training on the spot through
other means through investment as i said
before
to create a better opportunity i think
this is what we should should be doing
but once people um do come to europe
we need to to have procedures in place
and that's what what the commissioners
proposed a couple of weeks ago
that would offer especially from those
countries
people come from where we know they will
never have
the right to asylum because they don't
flee from war or natural disasters
that they get clarity very quickly
because now they can just play the
system very often
sometimes even for years coming from
countries where we
absolutely know they have nothing to
fear and still they can you know
if it gives them two years in europe
that they can work illegally etc
for two years those are for young people
these at least two years they're not
starving or they're not
they're not in in dire straits and even
if at the end they're then sent back
sometimes you know we're i think only
one third of the people are
actually sent back uh who don't have the
right to asylum so
that's part of the system that's i'm you
know the thing it
it sounds very harsh but i know
europe really well i think i can say
that if we don't
make the distinction very clear between
those who deserve to be protected and
those who don't
then we will not protect anyone because
then our population will say well if you
can't make that distinction we will not
accept anyone
and then people who actually flee from
persecution or war
will be will be refused asylum in europe
and that would be
then we take leave of our most
fundamental values but we're not a long
way from there if we don't fix the
system
mr timmerman um thank you very much for
a very interesting and engaging
interview
it was my pleasure uh and um well
i really hope uh south africa will be
doing extremely well and i miss it and i
hope to be back soon as soon as we can
travel
and um all the best to you and to your
loved ones and stay safe
and and to you and i hope to see you
here in this country um
sometime soon thank you very much have a
lovely day cheers